if we don't have a sense of purpose then
you're doing the thing you're doing just
for the sake of doing it I'm making
money just for the sake of money I'm
turning this wrench just for the sake of
turning this wrench and when we do
things that contribute to something else
contribute to something bigger it gives
our lives and our work meaning and when
we have a sense of meaning when we have
a sense of purpose it does many many
things to us it builds our
self-confidence it makes us better
decision makers it makes us better in
relationships and at the end of the day
it makes us enjoy our lives and find
fulfillment in our work and I think so
often a lot of people don't think about
it this way they don't think about
what's the purpose of all of this we
usually default to I gotta pay my bills
that's a function because I was told to
do it because everybody has to work or
because I want to make this company the
biggest or the best to what end to what
value and so to truly understand purpose
I think like I said it it sort of just
just has positive effects all over the
place need motivation what a top 10 with
a believe Nation hey it's Evan
Carmichael and I make these videos
because in my first business I quit I'm
a business partner I struggled to keep
going I was making 300 bucks a month and
felt like a complete failure and the
thing that saved me that pulled me up
was studying the stories of famous
entrepreneurs I got the motivation from
them I also got the strategies of what
to do next so that I can go off and
achieve my dreams and quite honestly I
still need the stories today myself to
continue my motivation to take it to the
next level so today this one from one of
the best Simon sinek and my take on this
top 10 was a success enjoy
rule number two adopt an optimist
mindset what is that Optimist mindset
means
so I think there's a great
misunderstanding of what optimism and
what an optimist is
um you know I think people think
optimism and blind positivity are the
same thing and they're not blind
positivity everything's good
everything's fine everything's good
which a lot of leaders think they have
to do they think they have to be
positive all the time to keep their team
motivated inspired and the reality is it
actually backfires because when we're
going through stress
we actually and we see our leader always
positive always positive we think
there's something wrong with us it
actually backfires optimism is different
optimism is not naive optimism is very
realistic optimism is the undying belief
that the future is bright
and we can be in a dark tunnel and say
these are hard times and I do not know
how long we will be here but I do not
know how far away that light is but I
know that if we work together we will
come out of this better than we went in
optimism again is about the future but
it is it is absolutely accepting of
difficulty and stress in the current day
rule number three is focus on
Improvement talk about competition a
little bit because my God
we're we're hyper focused on beating
people on being right on on competition
I'm afraid of it I need to work harder
like on talk about that a little bit how
we can shift that culture
so my my life and my work has been very
much influenced by a philosopher named
Dr James karst who in the mid-1980s uh
defined these two types of games finite
games and infinite games
um a finite game is defined as known
players
fixed rules and it agreed upon objective
football baseball
um there's if there's a winner
necessarily there have to be losers and
there's always a beginning and middle
and end uh to a finite game
uh then you have infinite games infinite
games are defined as known and unknown
players which means you don't
necessarily know who all the other
players are and new players can join at
any time
um uh the rules are changeable which
means every player can play however they
want
and the objective is to perpetuate the
game to stay in the game as long as
possible so we're players in infinite
games every day of Our Lives whether we
know it or not you know you can't win
education
you can come in first with a finite
amount of time you're at school where we
agree upon the time frames the school
year and the metrics grades but we don't
nobody wins education nobody wins
learning nobody wins health care nobody
wins global politics and nobody wins
business
but when you hear the language of so
many people they talk about being number
one being the best and beating their
competition
based on what based upon what agreed
upon objectives metrics or time frames
and this is a problem
because when we play with a finite
mindset in an infinite game and we play
to win in a game that has no Finish Line
there are some very predictable and
consistent outcomes the big ones are the
decline of trust the decline of
cooperation the decline of innovation
and when people become obsessed with
beating their competitors in a game
where there is actually no winner right
there's no winning career you can get a
promotion sure but there's no winning
career and there's no winning in
business
um and so beating your competition is
actually
based on what
based on revenues profit based on what
one year five years ten years the
lifespan of the company like what what
this is it's all nonsense it's all made
up
and so we spend so much time reacting to
what another player has done rather than
focusing on how we can improve
and so one of the things that I've
learned is to completely eliminate this
idea of having competitors
which is I have no competitors in my
space none there are other players who
do what I do
and some of those players do some of the
things that I do better than me and
those players are my worthy Rivals
and it is better to respect and study
your worthy Rivals because their
strengths reveal to you your weaknesses
um and if you can have your weaknesses
revealed to you that means you can work
on your weaknesses because ultimately as
individuals as organizations we're in a
state of constant Improvement that's all
we're trying to do is be better today
than we were yesterday be better
tomorrow than we were today that's all
this game is whether it's your life your
relationships your business whatever it
is it's a game of constant Improvement
and so to obsess about beating your
competition actually takes us away from
constant Improvement because it might
make us do something uh short term or it
might make us do something expedient
because it gives us a short-term leg up
or use cheaper ingredients or trick
somebody or you know because it can
drive revenues and all that does is
weaken our own organization that's all
it does that's all it does
and so I don't think of competitors at
all I think of worthy Rivals and by the
way where the arrivals can change you
know I get to pick who they are and I
get to pick the reasons that they're my
worthy Rivals and I'm in a state of
constant Improvement thanks to them
and sometimes it's something small and
sometimes it's something big but I'm
grateful to all those who do similar
things to me because it makes me a
better player rule number four is build
a trusting team we have to have trusting
teams
I was on a business trip in
Las Vegas
and they put me up at the Four Seasons
beautiful hotel
and one of the reasons it's a beautiful
hotel is not simply because of the fancy
bed any hotel can buy a fancy bed it's
because of the people who work there
that when they say hello to you you get
the distinct sense that they wanted to
say hello not that they were told to say
hello we're highly attuned social
animals we can tell the difference
they happen to have a coffee bar in the
lobby
and so one afternoon I went to buy
myself a cup of coffee and the Barista
working that day was a young man named
Noah
Noah was funny he was engaging I enjoyed
buying a cup of coffee from him I stood
there for far too long buying a cup of
coffee just because I enjoyed talking to
Noah so as is my nature I asked Noah do
you like your job
and without skipping a beat Noah says to
me I love my job
now in my line of business that's
significant like is rational I like the
people I like the challenge I get paid
well I like my job love is emotional it
demonstrates an emotional connection to
whatever we're doing do you love your
wife I like her a lot it's a it's a it's
a different standard right
Noah said I love my job so immediately
I'm interested
so I follow up I said to Noah tell me
specifically
what the Four Seasons is doing that you
would say to me you love your job and
again without skipping a beat Noah said
that throughout the day
managers will walk past them and ask him
how he's doing I ask them if there's
anything that he needs to do his job
better
not just his manager any manager
and then he said I also work for a
different Hotel
and there the managers walked past me
and catch me if I'm doing something
wrong
there they're always overbearing and
trying to make sure that I make my
numbers he says there I just like to get
through the day keep my head below the
radar and just collect my paycheck
he said only at the Four Seasons do I
feel I can be myself
this is the exact same human being and
yet the level of performance will be
completely different not because of him
but because of the leadership
environment in which he's working I get
this question all the time Simon how do
we get the most out of our people
they're not a towel that we ring them to
see how much we can get out of them the
question is flawed the correct question
is what environment do I have to create
what do I have to do to help my people
work at their natural best that's called
leadership
and when we can create a trusting team
s in which people feel trusted and
trusting
what will happen is it makes them feel
safe enough to raise their hand and say
I made a mistake
or I'm having trouble at home and it's
affecting my work
or you've promoted me to a position that
I don't know what I'm doing and I need
more training
or I need help or I'm scared
if we do not have trusting teams
what we have is a group of people who
show up to EV to work every single day
lying hiding and faking they hide all of
the mistakes for fear of getting in
trouble
they won't admit that they don't know
what they're doing for fear that they'll
be humiliated
they're certainly not going to say that
they're scared or that they need help
for fear that it will somehow reduce
their value inside the organization and
eventually things will compound and
break also to make sure you're actually
taking action after watching this video
I've designed a special free worksheet
just for this video the worksheet will
highlight all the Lessons Learned in
this video as well as pull out our three
favorite learnings and quotes that will
inspire you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business I'll see you
there rule number five is be a risk
taker you can't incentivize results like
you can't do that you can only
incentivize the behavior that will
achieve a certain result and if it's
only about the short term then guess
what you're going to drive a behavior
that drives short term and so in your
case what are the behaviors that you're
recognizing and rewarding and so if
people are getting bonused only for
hitting numbers
and they're not getting bonus for how
they do business then you're going to
incentivize a certain Behavior so I'll
give you an example so young in my
career I worked at an ad agency and I
was the junior dogs buddy to the junior
dogs buddy and it was traditional for a
big new business pitch that the senior
folks would run the pitch well it
happened to be around Christmas time and
all the senior folks went on vacation
and so me and one other Junior person
who were left behind because we didn't
go on vacation we're told to prepare the
War Room which basically means take a
conference room and fill it up with all
the research Well that took a few hours
right but we still had a week and so she
and I decided to write the whole pitch
we went through all the research and we
came up with a strategy and we wrote the
pitch all the senior leaders came back
we presented our work and they actually
used our strategy in this new business
pitch and we lost the pitch we didn't
win and I got a huge promotion my boss
actually moved me up two levels inside
the company
because he wasn't rewarding my
performance he was awarding and
rewarding my initiative by by giving me
a promotion for taking the risk to do
the extra work guess what I did after
that took more risks and did more work
even if it meant it didn't winning or
losing didn't become the primary factor
for me it was the initiative that but
that wasn't because of me and my and my
innate anything that's because that's
the behavior my boss wanted from me
and so I think what happens when we get
big is we be we do become too obsessed
with the result and we don't consider
the behavior there are some brilliant
people making big decisions who may have
missed the number or may have missed the
goal but we gave them nothing
which sends a subconscious message to
the rest of the company which is if you
hit your numbers you'll do well here if
you don't hit your numbers we don't care
how you do it as long as you know so you
get the point so I think I think it
happens big companies need to go back
and reevaluate how they recognize and
reward
um uh and what if you want if you want
risk taking then recognize the people
taking risks even when they fail rule
number six is Embrace uncertainty when
covid first showed up
I loved listening to the commentaries
the number of people who said in these
uncertain times
and I would always giggle to myself
because all times are uncertain there's
never been a time in history that wasn't
uncertain
um all that happened was something that
we didn't expect happened suddenly that
reminded us
you know that things are uncertain every
stock market crashed nobody knew that
was going to happen tomorrow it's always
uncertain and this is where finite Minds
an infinite mindset rather this is where
an infinite mindset could be very
valuable
because players who play with a finite
mindset
fear uncertainty and work hard to avoid
surprise which is why they like short
time frames we like the quarter or most
the year don't talk to me about three
years or five years that that freaks me
out and I like everything to go
according to Bland and be very
predictable and so when something
unexpected happens Panic is their normal
reaction right when you learn
when we learn to embrace an infinite
mindset
we actually see opportunity in Surprise
and we Embrace uncertainty
so when something unexpected happens
it's still stressful but when something
unexpected happens we go oh I wonder
what we can do with this this is
exciting hey team come here let's talk
about how do we work in these in these
in this environment
and I saw it happen during covet it was
so easy to see which companies were
playing with a finite mindset in which
we're playing with an infinite mindset
because the finite-minded companies
panicked
and went into survival mode and
everything was about themselves how are
we going to survive how are we gonna
make money right whereas the ones with
the infinite mindset went okay
opportunity here what if we were to
start our company from scratch today how
would we do things like what if we
didn't exist yesterday and today was the
first day of work how would we do things
still very stressful but very exciting
and instead of putting themselves at the
center they were very more preoccupied
with the customer people still want what
we have how do we get it to them as
opposed to how can we make money
and so I could tell the difference
immediately and so the more we learned
to embrace an infinite mindset
uncertainty becomes a joy becomes an
opportunity for creativity and so it's
that's one of the huge benefits rule
number seven is be open to feedback is
there practical things we can do to
crack culture seeking out that feedback
and creating a safe space well the
simple answers of course
um the there's no such thing as a single
Silver Bullet It's a combination of
things it's like what's the one thing I
can do to happy have a happy
relationship well I I can't I can tell
you a important thing but I can't tell
you the important thing so it's the same
um and everybody's a little different
you know and each culture is a little
different so there's there's not even a
set list I can get but there's some
things that people can choose from you
know one thing is one of the ways we
create space is how we react right if
someone gives you feedback and you deny
it
well that's a problem
if somebody gives you hard feedback and
you thank them for it
a very different environment it creates
so I I I'll give you two uh examples one
a lesson the other one a practical
example that someone can use so I had
the opportunity to visit the Army
Rangers uh Ranger school in particular I
know where they make they make army
rangers and one of the uh
troubles they had a bunch of years ago
was they had these folks that they
called Spotlight Rangers which was they
were really good at their job like they
were brilliant at all the tasks that
were set to them strong
they're the teachers the instructors
loved them they stood out they were
great they were motivated but as soon as
the spotlight was turned off when the
instructor wasn't there and they were
back at Barracks they were and
the only person who the only people who
knew were their with their friends and
colleagues because the spotlight was
turned off
and so the Army Rangers implemented a
system of peer review in order to
identify Spotlight Rangers and in now by
the way they started this 40 years ago
which I find incredibly Advanced
um but to advance through Ranger school
you need to pass three tests you need
your instructor to say yep you're ready
to go to the next level you need to
physically actually perform all the
tasks required of you and you need to
pass your peer review
um and if you fail any one of those
three you don't make it to the next
level
interesting and so that becomes an
equally weighted component of
advancement in the Army Rangers which is
what kind of team player are you
which I love
so we implemented a system of 360 review
um which was sort of a bit of an
amalgamation of things we've taken from
other groups and made our own
where what we what the way it works is
um
you take the group of people you have
regular interaction with
and
you
um
fill out
uh your top three
weaknesses
or the places you believe you need to
grow the most
with a specific example for each so top
three specific weaknesses or places you
need to grow the most and then top three
specific strengths
or the places you believe
three examples of the places you believe
you've grown the most they have to be
specific
not like Oh I'm a much better time
keeper now not that you've got to give
some specific examples
they're collated and distributed amongst
the team
and then you come together as a group
and you take turns
reading them
so first you read your own weaknesses
and then the group has the opportunity
to add to that list
and here's the best part we give a
little speech before the whole exercise
starts that the people who are going to
give you this feedback
really don't want to
it's really uncomfortable for them it's
going to be uh they they would just
rather not do this exercise at all
but they're going to do it because they
want to see you and help you grow
and so what they're giving you is a gift
and so you have to receive it as a gift
which means you say thank you
you don't have to agree with it if you
don't agree with it say thank you and
just dismiss it it's fine
but if it has an emotional impact if it
makes you angry
frustrated
probably true
right and we go around the room and
somebody's tell they every people can
add to this list of these weaknesses in
any way there's no format they can do it
in any way they want and you sit there
and you look them in the eye and you
genuinely say thank you you're not
allowed to say a word except thank you
then you do your strengths and you read
your threat strengths and anyone can add
to the list
and just as you discovered you have
blind spots you didn't know you have you
discovered that you have strength that
you didn't know you had that you're
having a positive impact on the lives of
others that you didn't know you were
and it's a magical experience there's
usually tears at some point because it's
powerful and it's a safe environment
rule number eight is live an infinite
life what does it mean to live an
infinite life
clearly our lives are finite we're born
we die but life is infinite
we come we go and the game continues
with us without us which means every
single one of us has the choice of how
we choose to live our lives how we
choose to lead our organizations we can
lead with a finite mindset try and make
more money than our friends try and get
ahead faster than everybody else try and
achieve more power than anybody else and
when we die we take none of it with us
but the choice to live an infinite life
means we choose to build an organization
that will be better off because we work
there we will leave it in better shape
than we found it
it means to be the kind of friend and
leader to others that they will be
better because we were in their lives it
means we will literally live on Beyond
ourselves
it's just a choice whether we choose to
live with an infinite mindset or a
finite mindset rule number nine is find
your passion does this walk me through
because I'm actually very curious about
you before you do you know what I mean
like that's what I'm really kind of
curious about so you didn't you were
like disgruntled with your career a
little bit right I wouldn't say
disgruntled it I'd fallen out of love
yeah okay I was I had no passion
for my career okay this was a chosen
career like I started my own business in
the category in a profession that I
thought I wanted to spend the rest of my
life in marketing oh okay you know and
uh and to wake up one morning with a
superficially good life I own my own
business we had amazing clients we did
really good work our clients liked us
and didn't want to do it anymore right
it's kind of distressing because as I as
I said where we started you know so many
of us intertwine our identities with our
work and if I don't like my work then
who am I right and so I went through
that
um which uh was incredibly unfun
um and it was the discovery of this of
this little idea that I called the
Golden Circle you know where we all know
what we do some of us know how we do it
but very few of us know why we do what
we do and I realized I didn't know why I
was doing what I was doing
um and it was uh it was that crisis
that was designed to do nothing more
than help me find my own passion to get
back my my mojo
um that put me in a path that was um
unexpected
um uh my my entire career is an accident
you know amazing um I am a living proof
that uh that you couldn't that you don't
have to have a plan right right exactly
and it worked out for you right
right you have to have a Direction but
you definitely don't need to know the
individual steps and Rule Number 10 the
last home before some very special bonus
Clips is serve others the part of the
maturation of your work
is and a pretty clear the mission of you
know
helping people rather than always you
know the over almost the over
consumption of self-help
right so the framework of your own
company just give me a a second on that
and how you're looking to move that
needle
yeah so there's an entire section in the
Bookshop called self-help but there's no
Bookshop there's no section the Bookshop
called help others
um and I think that's the thing we're
missing you know I I think since the
1970s when the self-help industry began
it it's done very well for itself
um uh uh and the question is is it has
taught us a skill but it's it's also
teaching us to to be preoccupied with
ourselves
and I think as social animals one of the
things we've forgotten is we also need
to learn to help each other and if you
look at some of the challenges that
plague us today whether it's
disengagement at work or loneliness at
home or struggle to find the job we love
or funding find the relationship that we
love you know uh all of those things the
antidote to all of those things is
another human being
and the our ability to help somebody
else find the thing that they're looking
for actually is uh actually gives us the
thing we're looking for uh and I'm
living proof of that it's when I learned
when I learned the value of service
everything that I wanted to feel
everything that I wanted to achieve
started to fall in place only when I
learned to to serve others first
millennials
were difficult but this younger
generation they're more activists which
when it's you know when it's like
climate change we love it but like when
you're like the intern and you're
sending an email to the CEO going I
don't think that you like it's like you
know there's other ways to do that
[Music]
uh
it starts with empathy it starts with
empathy and we have to understand
it doesn't it's For Better or For Worse
the changing nature of what work has
become in our lives if you go back a
bunch of decades it used to be that you
got your sense of purpose from church
you got your sense of community from
bowling league you got you had you you
knew your neighbors you barbecued with
them on the weekends and work we were I
was loyal to work and work was loyal to
me at some point I'd get a gold watch
aside there's an entire generation that
when I talk about the gold watch they
have no idea what I'm talking about
right that's how much the world has
changed
um and and work was simply a place that
I made a living to pay my bills but
there was I still enjoyed my you know I
I it was still loyalty
over the course of time attendance
church attendance is down bowling clubs
don't exist anymore we don't talk to our
neighbors we become very insular and
what's happened is all of that pressure
is now being put on the office I now
expect my company to be the place where
I get my purpose the place I get my
friendships the place I get my community
at the place I get my social life now
we've also added the place you have to
agree with all of my politics
right that's a new one
and it's even now especially during
covet it's gone up even higher
especially for this young group where
you also have to be my my therapists my
therapy I'm going to bring all of my
problems to work
and where we the idea of emotional
professionalism seems to have gone away
you know where you actually see people
sitting in meetings like this you're
like what's going on having a bad day
right that's emotionally unprofessional
right you can I want you to bring your
emotions to work I want you to bring
your whole self to work but but for the
same reason that we exercise emotional
professionalism and other aspects of Our
Lives we also do it at work
so one of the struggles of this young
generation is they are not equipped on
how to deal with stress
they're just less equipped than previous
generations for various reasons
including social media internet and all
that and you know parenting and all the
rest of it there's many reasons for it
but they're really not good at dealing
with stress they're really bad at
dealing with confrontation they're so
confrontation avoidance
that they would rather ghost someone
than break up with them after dating
them for six months
right that they would rather quit their
job than ask their boss for a raise
and usually in spectacular fashion like
you don't value me you don't pay me
enough you're like if you just asked I
would have given you a raise and we love
you
but they quit because they're just
afraid of the conversation
so they're very intimidated by
confrontation they're ill-equipped to
deal with stress
there's an emotional immaturity
emotional and professionalism
right and this it's not a good thing or
a bad thing it just is
and so us having empathy and
understanding that is important and so
it raises the question how are they
dealing with their stress not well and
so there's a new phenomenon that I'm
seeing happening in a lot of offices
where especially young people are
finding the one or two empathetic the
empaths on the team and they're going to
them with all of their problems and it's
not the traditional I hate my boss I
hate my job venting about work is fine I
have no issue with that but it's I hate
my mom I don't know what I want to do
with my life when am I going to leave my
house what I you know my boyfriend's not
working out my girlfriend's not working
out like every problem in my life on
this one or two people at work and we've
had it happen on our team we had three
people quit
and I got a little team I got three
people who quit because they said they
were burnt out and I was like
you I know how much work you do what do
you mean you're burnt out so I'm like do
you have another job on the side
[Applause]
what I discovered
is they were the impasse on the team and
everybody was calling them to unload
they were burnt out because they were
taking on everybody's stress and they
were exhausted they couldn't take it
anymore and they just quit
and when I talked about this publicly I
had a 23 year old come up to me in one
of the companies and said
I do that
and so we have to recognize they are
struggling
in a changing chaotic crazy world right
now where there's so much uncertainty in
this world like like the world is always
uncertain but my God it's War and the
countries added each other's throat and
there's challenge in the global warming
and it's just insane these poor kids and
they have no outlet they don't know how
to deal with it so my my big challenge
my big uh it's a challenge for all of us
is how do we hold space for them and the
problem is is they don't even recognize
when we're doing the right thing for
them that's the hardest part
a lot of anger
um but it's it's gonna the problem is
it's going to take a bit like we're in a
period of extreme flux
and it's it's not going to settle for a
little bit where it's going to be very
bumpy a very bumpy road for the next few
years there's no right answer
and you will be you will be um
you know no good deed will go unpunished
the human brain cannot comprehend the
negative
it is incapable
yes it's true I'll give you an example
[Music]
okay no no I'll give you an example you
don't have to believe
it okay the human brain cannot
comprehend the negative you ready
don't think of an elephant
uh
you can't you can't tell the human brain
not to do something right and so what
happens is we very often reinforce
things when we put things in the
negative right I can't get apart
I can't get apart
I can't get apart right or
um
um I can't do this
versus I'm going to keep doing this
I'm going to keep doing this
right
um and and it's it's such a huge thing
to to convert things into the
affirmative you're supposed to do it
with children as well we're supposed to
say instead of saying to children don't
eat on the couch we're supposed to say
eat at the table
right we tell people what we want them
to do not want them what we don't want
to do pilots know this right it is well
known in the pilot community that when
you tell a pilot don't hit the obstacle
they'll hit the obstacle because what
they're doing is focusing on the
obstacle
skiers know this
if if you ever seen skiers go through
trees
do you know how they do that it's very
easy it's actually surprisingly easy if
you go through trees on skis and you go
don't hit a tree don't hit a tree don't
hit a tree guess what you're watching
you're only looking at trees
all you're doing is seeing dreams you
don't understand how anyone can ski with
all these trees
right as opposed to follow the snow
follow the path follow the path the only
thing you see is the path
skiers know this if you say don't hit a
tree you'll hit a tree you won't be able
to find a path because all you see is
millions of trees if you say only follow
the path you actually don't see any
trees there's actually very sparse trees
there's plenty of path there's plenty of
snow
it's the same thing for you if you focus
on the obstacles all you will see is
obstacles if you focus on the path
through the trees
all you will see is path through the
trees
it's your choice how you choose to
perceive your own career it's literally
perspective the U.S marine told me the
first Criterion for being a leader is
you have to want to be one
um and if you look at the way the
Marines select their leaders select
their officers it's a it's different
than than with their enlisted core so if
you enlist in the Marine Corps you go to
Paris Island in the East or you go to
San Diego in the west to to boot camp
and they will make you into a marine
that's what it says we make Marines yeah
and uh if you change your mind
you're gonna be in the Marine Corps
whether you like it or not there is no
changing your mind yeah once you sign on
the dotted line you're in yeah in the
office of core it's different if you
want to be an officer in the Marine
Corps you go to OCS and Quantico
Virginia
um and uh it's a 10-week training
and uh you only have to stay in the
first four weeks uh for the next six
weeks you can drop out at any time for
any reason yeah
um and the reason is is because if you
don't want to be a leader they don't
want you yeah they give you the choice
um you know leadership to me is like is
like is like being a parent everybody
has the capacity to be a parent doesn't
mean everybody wants to be a parent and
everybody should be a parent right
leadership is the same everybody has the
capacity yeah it doesn't mean everybody
wants it and doesn't mean everybody
should yeah it comes a great personal
sacrifice it means you have to
constantly worry about other people like
being a parent yeah
um you have to uh love them whether you
chose them or not yeah you know yeah uh
your team
uh and uh and there are skills to being
a parent and everyone who's ever had a
child starts reading books when they
find out that they're pregnant for the
first time you know uh they start asking
their friends they start asking their
parents for advice and it's constant you
know whether the kid's struggling at
school or struggling at home or having a
good time there's it's all the things
like I I hate hanging out with my sister
and my brother-in-law when they're with
their their other friends who have
families because all they talk about is
kids yeah right
um uh well leadership's the same yeah
leadership's the same you know the the
great leaders that I know are all
students of leadership they're obsessed
they're constantly talking about it
they're reading books about it they're
watching talks about it they're reading
articles about it they get together they
it's it's the topic of conversation sure
um and so you know if you want to learn
the skill set I mean number one you have
to want to do it
um and B you're gonna have to do some
work yeah I mean it takes it takes
effort this is one of the most common
mistakes I see of visionary uh uh
founding leaders whether it's Sam Walton
there's Steve Jobs like we know who
these people are Richard Branson we know
who these people are Elon Musk right and
one of the biggest mistakes they all
make is they think that everyone in the
company is as clear on their Vision as
they are
uh because it's clear to them they just
assume it's clear to everyone
and they don't think they need to go
through the process of of putting that
just cause in terms that have nothing to
do with the company or themselves and uh
the the work that they uh fail to do in
acculturating the vision outside of them
because they're they have such outsized
influence over the course of the course
of the organization and we talked about
courage before they're the ones who say
no to to the pressures of Wall Street
for example
um unfortunately so many of them uh
replace themselves with operators a
Visionary replaces himself with an
operator now inherently that's not
necessarily A Bad Thing operators can
absolutely do a Visionary job but they
have to know that it's a different job
and the skill set that they've developed
over a 20 or 30 year career being a CFO
or CEO getting really good at it
actually has to change and so so many of
these folks replace themselves with
their CFO or their CEO and when asked
why did you choose that person they all
say the same thing I trust them more
than any buddy true they know more about
the workings of this company than I do
true I couldn't do it without them true
except for the fact that it's a
different skill set one is up and out
the other one is down and in and again
yes a CFO or CEO could take over that
CEO role but have to understand that up
and out is now their job that being in
the weeds and in the details and
worrying about the short term is no
longer their job
uh um and I think we actually do
ourselves a disservice in business by
thinking of CFOs or CEOs is number two
in the company you know that many of
them think they're in line for the big
job
um and it's one in a it's a partnership
it's Visionary and operator who it's the
push me pull you it's the tension of
those two skill sets and those two ways
of operating up and out and down and in
that uh you know very very long term to
Shorter term that make an organization
highly highly highly functional
um and so uh so one of the things we
have to do is you want a Visionary
person and a Visionary job
you want an operator and an operator job
you want to do the the hard work of
extracting that why that purpose from
that founder leader in terms that are
compelling uh and resonant with everyone
else and you want to make sure that your
values are built in and built into your
incentive structure not just performance
but your values as well so that the
organization is equipped to survive that
founder leader for a century if
necessary or more I had
um two fish bowls in my room
and we can calculate you know we know
the average lifespan we know our average
lifespan it's you know whatever the
number is 78 or whatever it is so you
can actually easily calculate the number
of
months weeks or days that you
statistically have left on this planet
right
um and so I bought a bag of marbles and
one marble represented each week that I
have left on the planet
and I filled up the exact number based
on the statistics in one fishbowl
and at the and it's it's more it's more
inspiring than doomsday
uh I mean it's just statistics yeah no
no but at the end of every week I would
ask myself
um I actually got it down to the day but
at the end of every week I'd say was
this a week worth living did I do
something to inspire someone
and it's my own standard and if the
answer is yes I move it to the other
Fishbowl if the answer is no I throw
away the marble because I wasted it
right
um and uh and that's why I love the word
inspire I believe it is a standard to
live by and inspiration is what how we
make other people feel you know it's not
did you do something I did something
good today I gave money to charity
that's not what it is it's how did I
make someone feel and did they feel
that their their life is even better
even for five minutes because of
something because of their interaction
with me right
um and then genuine care I think is the
second part of it right yeah
Inspire the world
to lead with genuine heart right with
genuine heart and again I think that
sets you up for values like you know and
it's proprietary I've never heard
anybody talk about genuine people talk
about Innovation and you know Integrity
like those are generic words
but genuine heart is something you can
own and so how do you amplify a genuine
heart
um what are the standards of of of
leading with genuine heart what does it
mean to lead with General heart what are
the values that mean that are you giving
out a genuine heart award you know to
the person in each property who
exemplifies and by the way the way to do
that is to ask their teammates to vote
for them not come from leadership
like who who inspires us to leave with
genuine heart to the degree that we want
to be more like our own colleague
because a peer review is actually more
powerful than than a review from from uh
from up on high because really we're all
working for one person's approval where
a peer review is my team loves me and
we're not angry when somebody wins that
award I deserve that because I voted for
him because I voted for him right
um
um and it sets a standard for the rest
of the team so so I think uh peer review
where we allow our own people to choose
who within our group who within our team
has inspired us to lead with genuine
heart and the irony is they may not be
your best individual performer
but they're probably your best natural
leaders
it doesn't necessarily always line up
with with performance
we like many
um made most of our money from in person
and Live Events and workshops and of
course that instantaneously disappeared
um and so we like many were forced to
Pivot
um and we took advantage of online
learning but we wanted to do it
consistent with our own values
um we did live classes
um because we wanted to retain some sort
of human connection as opposed to just
on-demand classes we called up people
who we knew who work whose work we
admired and we said you're struggling
too why don't you come and do you share
your your Genius on our platform
um and it became a very Cooperative
thing but there's a few tactics that I
learned to get from A to B that were
really helpful that I never would have
done if I didn't have that extreme
pressure so one of the things we did is
we we shared with the team the vision
which we had and then we said to the
whole team uh we can't do this alone
this is this is literally a team effort
and so what I want is I want 15 ideas
from each person in the next 48 hours
about how we can deliver on that vision
and the team freaked out
15 ideas and 48 hours and if they wanted
to work in teams I was fine with that
um and I and and the reason for that is
um the pressure you know if I gave them
three weeks well they would have all
done the work the 48 hours before anyway
so you know uh uh uh so that was
academic but the important thing was the
reason for 15 ideas is because if I only
ask for two or three or three or four
those would be the same ideas I came up
with
um uh and I wanted it's the idea that 11
12 and 13 that were the brilliant ones
and when we came together to report out
we did it in sort of a unique way I sort
of gave this little speech where I said
okay
um uh this is not a competition this is
about contribution
if one person has six Amazing Ideas and
you have none instead of being angry say
thank you because they just saved your
job because they had a great idea
also what I learned is that there's a
there's a difference between somebody
who has an idea and someone who's good
at executing an idea and the reality is
the most creative people in the team
that could come up with the ideas
weren't the best at executing them and
the ones that didn't have that many
ideas they were great at executing ideas
so it became really interesting and to
see who are my creators and who are my
executors from that one meeting
and we played Boggle rules if you've
ever played the game Boggle if somebody
else has your word you just skip over it
and move on I said if somebody says your
idea don't bother saying well I had that
idea too I'm not keeping score I don't
care simply move on and tell me
something else on your list and we only
let people report out two or three ideas
at a time that way we could sort of get
a flavor and what ended up happening was
people would build on the ideas that
they heard and the set of ideas that we
had at the end became our ideas nobody
could claim them anymore because we'd
all sort of tinkered with them and then
we broke them into three buckets green
yellow and red a green idea was an idea
we could execute with the money we had
and we could execute it within the week
a yellow idea was an idea that needed a
little more resource probably take a
week to a month and a red idea no matter
how good it was was too expensive or
take too long and we just parked it and
said we'll deal with those one day and
we just took all our green ideas and
executed them so ethical fading is a
really amazing and fascinating social
phenomenon
uh basically what it is is when a group
of people make unethical decisions
believing that they have are still
consistent with their own ethical
framework in other words they don't
think they've done anything unethical
right extreme examples of this would be
things like
um a pharmaceutical company raising the
price of an essential uh uh drug uh 500
800 a thousand percent five thousand
percent and though it may not be illegal
it's highly highly unethical
and and yet they don't think they've
done anything wrong
um uh that's an extreme example but we
see ethical fading happen all across
companies all the time
um where we do things that we know are
good for us where we might lie to our
our customers or our clients for example
or we might lie to each other to get
ourselves ahead you know this is all
these are all demonstrations of ethical
fading
um uh the way in which ethical fading
happens
um as you said one of the ways is just a
ridiculous unbalanced amount of pressure
on short term which forces us to think
about ourselves or or uh only think
about uh that short-term goal
um and then we can rationalize well
everyone's doing it it's what the
company wants me to do how else am I
going to get ahead I have to put food on
the table it's the system it's you know
like we can rationalize the behavior
um the also the slippery slope we do
something a little bit once it worked we
do it a little more it works we do a
little more at work so do it and before
you know it you have full-blown ethical
fading and so the way you combat ethical
fading and and like I said I gave you an
extreme example of the Pharmaceuticals
but we see low-level ethical fading
across a lot of companies unfortunately
um and the way you combat it is uh is
one uh uh good leadership uh where that
kind of thing is not tolerated so for
example it's it's totally normal for
people to have unethical ideas
um but the question is when when do they
get caught so in an unhealthy company
that that unethical idea is implemented
until social pressure or the law
intervenes or there's a scandal right
and then we say oh we're terribly sorry
we you know we're a very good company
after you got caught in a in a in a
properly ethical company somebody May
raise the idea in a meeting
and everybody in the meeting will go
that's funny but we would never do that
here
that's that's not us that's a little bit
unethical and we get it gets shut down
immediately
um and again that's good leadership
because it's the leaders who are
promoting people who are ethical who are
highlighting ethical behavior and acting
in a way that sets the tone and they're
not putting undue pressure on people to
break the rules in order to make the
numbers
um you know a lot of leaders
unfortunately when confronted with
toxicity or unethical Behavior they'll
struck their shoulders and say I know
but the numbers are so good and they
allow it to happen and so one of the
primary ways in which you beat ethical
fading quite frankly is is good
leadership but the others are just cause
you know trusting teams all of these
things contribute to operating in a
highly ethical way leaders need to Model
Behavior
um like parents need to Model Behavior
um so for example I'll give you you know
a company says you know we believe in
integrity and always telling the truth
and then the phone rings and you know an
assistant picks up the phone and and the
executive says
you know well congratulations you've
just sanctioned lying you know
um and so it's one thing to write it on
the wall it's another thing to actually
practice the thing that's written on the
wall
um so modeling the behavior is
absolutely essential
um because your actions will speak much
louder than your words
um and uh the stories do matter
um uh stories are much more powerful
than statistics what did Stalin say
um I'm quoting Stalin
um uh the death of one man is the the
death of one man is a tragedy the death
of a million is a statistic
I think he said it the other way around
the death of a million medicine tragedy
and I'll give you a real life example
um just to just to put it into into
so let's let's say something like okay
so um
uh covid ravaged uh the world
um some would argue expectedly some
would argue unexpectedly but it happened
and over the course of just over a year
um 600 000 people in the United States
alone have lost their lives
um many women uh children and fathers
and mothers and and families destroyed
by this by this this horrible uh virus
okay that's true right
here's Story number two
um I know this young woman who lives in
Northern uh Southern California her name
is Candy Yoder
Cami was driving home from work one day
and she turned the corner and Came Upon
a car accident that had just happened
the ambulance hadn't arrived yet
a 17 year old driver accidentally hit an
18 year old pedestrian with her car
the girl was lying on their on the
street one of her legs at an at a
um an uncomfortable angle a 90 degree
angle
um Cami pulled over her car got out
thank goodness she actually knows basic
uh first aid she performs CPR on the
young girl to keep her alive until the
the paramedics arrived
um eventually the paramedics came they
took over from Cami and they took the
girl to the hospital a couple of days
later Cami was curious what had happened
to her and she went on the the the blood
Arch you went on online and found out
that the young girl had actually died
which was more powerful to you the death
of 600 000 people or the death of one
young girl in California and the second
one gave you Goosebumps the first one
didn't and that's the point which is
what's the difference between 500 000
people dead or 600 000 people to 650 000
people dead it emotionally moves us zero
um but when you tell the story of a
person
who is an example
of what happens if we tell the story of
one death of kovid and how it's affected
that family the emotional impact is
vastly more powerful than simply
relaying statistics and numbers and so
yes I do believe that part of being a
good leader is not just the intent but
part of the leadership is the ability to
communicate those things are those
things I think are inextricably linked
and learning how to tell a story quite
frankly that captures the value of your
work because people can relay those
stories much easier than they can relay
or remember their statistics throughout
the organization throughout the
organization story gets passed down past
sometimes generations generationally and
and great organizations like great
cultures have a myth you know
um there there's stories that have been
passed down Generations in in Nations
about the founding you know the Marine
Corps celebrates their birthday every
year
um there's a debate whether that's
actually even their birthday or not it
doesn't even matter
right and and it becomes part of the
culture these stories become ingrained
you know George Washington and the
cherry tree yeah was it a cherry tree
yeah
um uh uh like the they become ingrained
in the fabric of the of the nation
so too do they become ingrained in the
fabric of the company and like religion
like anything it's the stories that
capture the morals and values much
better than just writing them on the
wall
so my why
is to inspire people to do the things
that Inspire them so together each of us
can change our world for the better
and it's why I wake up every morning
every day it is the greatest compliment
someone can pay me when they say to me
that was inspiring or you were inspiring
like that feeds me
you know
um and the interesting thing about a why
is because it is not it is objective
a why is the sum total of how we were
raised it's born out of the patterns and
the lessons we learned from our parents
from our teachers when we're young and
our Y is fully formed by the time we're
in our mid to late teens and you only
have one wife for the rest of your life
it doesn't change
you have you are who you are based on
how you were raised now you may not be
acting as your true self you know people
say that to us all the time you know
it's like I don't know who you are
anymore you know but when you are at
your natural best your wise front and
center but we're not always acting at
our natural best and sometimes we make
decisions out of selfishness we shake we
take the job that pays us that offers us
the most money and turn down the one to
work for somebody who would probably be
a better Mentor you know we do these
things all the time and so you know can
you tweak the words of your why of
course you know but that's that's
semantics
um can we find better ways to to bring a
why to life yes that's the evolution but
the why itself is fixed can you off the
top of your head can you think of you
talked to you compared you know the
finite mindset to some things with law
enforcement sure as far as infinite can
you think of anything off the top of
your head where you could relate that
specifically to what we do what that
might look like anybody who's wearing a
uniform here knows this because you've
had this experience in your career right
which is treating someone with dignity
that's right
treating someone with dignity has
nothing to do
whether they are guilty or innocent
right
um that everybody here knows that when
you treat somebody with dignity the way
they respond to you even if they've
committed a crime and they're sitting
there in handcuffs is very very
different than when we don't treat them
with dignity so for example treating
someone with dignity may look like
somebody gets pulled over for expired
tags or something and you've they've got
a warrant I don't know and you have to
tow their car right
so you call a tow truck and now somebody
who's maybe financially struggling
you've just put at least 300 more that
they have to deal with
or treating them with dignity is like
hey I gotta I gotta tow your car before
I call a tow truck do you want to call
somebody you want to call a family
member or something who can come here
and get your car
um that'll save you 300 bucks you know
and help you out you know and if you
can't call somebody I'm gonna have to
tow it right that's treating someone
with dignity and everybody here knows
that when you treat somebody with
dignity sometimes you're taking them to
jail and they thank you
and the way in which people respond to
the uniform if treated with dignity has
nothing to do with breaking the law or
being put in handcuffs it's how it's
it's human being to human being and so I
think in a law enforcement uh when law
enforcement is conducted in the policing
organization you're thinking about the
longevity of the value of the uniform
you're thinking about the relationship
of of the the those who wear the uniform
in in public how much the public is
willing to help us if a crime is
committed and we go to public and say
can you help us and their willingness
those those things are determined right
now on a day-to-day basis right it and
you asked before about building of trust
right trust does there's no big thing
you can do that builds trust trust is
built up with lots and lots and lots of
tiny little innocuous little things
think of it like your own relationship
like you know have you ever been in love
the person you fell in love with you
there wasn't like I I bought you flowers
on Valentine's Day now you love me right
that's not how it works it's like you
know I went to the fridge to get myself
a drink and I got you one too without
you asking I woke up in the morning and
I said good morning to you before I
checked my phone there was a game on and
you said honey can I talk to you and I
paused the game and said what's on your
mind right I'm being idealistic I mean
uh
uh my point is there's no one of those
made someone fall in love or trust you
but it's the combination and
accumulation of all those tiny little
individually innocuous things that would
say I believe you and I trust you now
imagine an entire organization where
we're just trying to do our job we just
have to enforce the law we have to do
these things these are the rules this is
how we do it but the manner in which we
conduct ourselves each one innocuous
unto itself
over the course of time builds
tremendous Trust
with an organization and the community
so that when you need to pull from that
Trust Bank when you need to make a make
a make a withdrawal right because
something's gone really horribly wrong
and maybe there was somebody who acted
illegally within the department that you
get to say to the community we screwed
up and I need your help to be patient
they go you're good
you're good but that that trust is
earned I don't think you can motivate
the unmotivated I I don't think you
could motivate people people either are
motivated or unmotivated I think you can
inspire people
um and uh and you know you can motivate
people with sticks and carrots you know
offer them Bounty or threatened
punishment and you'll get behavior that
you want
is there loyalty is their love
absolutely not
um usually when people are unmotivated
it's not necessarily them it might be
the situation they're in
um maybe they don't belong in the
culture
um maybe they feel unseen or unheard
maybe they're scared maybe they're
unprepared so we we have to you know
when somebody's unmotivated let's not
label them as unmotivated first what are
the 20 other things that it could also
be let's start there now are there some
people in the world who are made
unmotivated absolutely you hired them
which means you bear some responsibility
if it's if it's time to transition them
to help them find another place where
they're going to be a better fit we
can't yell at them and call them stupid
and motivated and push them out the door
we have to bear some of the
responsibility we hired them and if we
made a mistake and hired somebody who's
a bad cultural fit then we have to take
care of them and help them transition to
somewhere where they're going to be a
better fit
um I think that um you know if we only
focus on motivating people and that's a
factor then um you're only going to get
very finite thinking an excessive amount
of motivating things like hit this
number get this bonus uh you'll get a
motivated employee pool that doesn't
care about about each other might stab
each other in the back and eventually
will take a better job somewhere else we
have to inspire people we have to give
them that sense of cause and vision that
their work is worth more uh we have to
make them feel like they matter and feel
like they're seen and heard and
understood and what ends up happening is
those people are not only more motivated
and inspired but if they're offered a
better higher paying job somewhere else
they turn it down because it's not just
about the bonuses and the money it's
because they would rather be here with
these wonderful people you can pick your
unworthy Rivals
um you can pick any company for any
reason and say they're better than us
you know what can we learn from them
um I'll give you a real life story that
really captured this for me am I and
it's it's
um it's in the book but I'll tell it to
you
um uh
I spoke at a education Summit for
Microsoft
and then a few months later I was
invited to speak at an education Summit
for Apple
at the Microsoft Summit this back in
Steve Ballmer days
in the Microsoft Summit
um the vast majority of the
presentations by the executives spent
most of their time talking about how to
beat Apple
at the Apple Summit 100 of the
presentations were how to help teachers
teach and how to help students learn
one was obsessed with beating their
competition the other one was obsessed
with advancing their mission
um at the end of my talk at Microsoft
they gave me a gift
they gave me the Zune when it was a
thing this was Microsoft's response to
the iPod
and this little piece of technology I
have to say was really very very good it
was quite a good little piece of
technology it didn't work on an Apple so
I couldn't use it that's a different
problem
but it was it was very good
um so at the end of my Apple talk I was
sharing a taxi with an apple executive
and I couldn't help myself I just had to
stir the pot
and I turned to him I go you know
Microsoft gave me their new Zune and it
is so much better than my iPod Touch
and he turned to me and he said I have
no doubt
and the conversation was over
because he understood this was an
infinite minded organization he
understood
that sometimes
the your competitor will do something
better than you and sometimes you'll be
better than them there's no such thing
as winning or losing there's only a head
in behind and where Microsoft was
obsessed with beating apple apple was
obsessed without doing itself
and so the great irony is just a couple
years after that Apple released the
iPhone
so where Microsoft was obsessing with
how to make a better iPod Apple was on
to the next thing didn't even care and
that's the whole idea which is
absolutely study and learn from the
other players you see I don't even call
them competitors the other players in
your industry so see what they're doing
better like I said it reveals your
weaknesses and say we can do better than
than ourselves grow eventually they no
longer become worthy of comparison
anymore because you you advance
yourselves but the whole idea is Apple
is thinking about what they could do
next not how they could beat Microsoft
to get more market share for an iPod
so learn from others and how you can be
better absolutely like I said their
strengths reveal to your weaknesses and
that's a gift passion is not an input
passion is an output uh passion
um you know we're all passionate we're
just not all passionate for the same
things and we will feel what we call
passion when we are involved in
something that is deeply personal to us
that is helping us Advance some higher
purpose or cause then when we go to work
what we've what we experience is Passion
but if you make us do something that we
feel no personal connection to that is
not as helping Advance any kind of
bigger ideal than what we feel is stress
now passionate people work many hours
they don't come home they miss their
families they take business trips they
they don't sleep and yet it feels worth
it
people who are stressed go into business
trips they miss their families they work
long hours they don't sleep but it
doesn't feel worth it passion is an
output not an input like stress is an
output not an input
so you don't you can't do what you're
passionate about you find something you
believe in and what you will experience
is passion
so then it begs the question how do I
find what I believe in right there's a I
think Society especially our society and
especially for a younger generation puts
overwhelming pressure on us to have a
vision
what's your vision or find your bliss of
all of these they're all the same thing
right
and the problem is we're not all
Visionaries
it's unfair
it's an unfair standard that's like
telling everybody be to be creative but
we're not all creative where everybody
be good at math but we're not all good
at math
we're not all Visionaries only a small
percentage of our population are
actually visionary
you don't have to have a vision you have
to find a vision
right if you hear Martin Luther King say
I have a dream that one day little black
children will hold hands on the
playground with little white children
you go that's what I want
you choose to follow Dr King
when you hear the words of Visionaries
and if they appeal to you in some
visceral level they give you Goosebumps
they make you excited they make you want
to sacrifice be a part of it stand in
line to hear them pay money whatever it
is
follow that make that your vision take
it and say that's my vision too you can
adopt someone else's vision and make it
your own that's what we call a following
is we have taken the visionary's vision
and we have chosen to follow that Vision
ourselves we are followers that's a good
thing there's no difference between the
Visionary and the follower we both see
ourselves in service to something bigger
than ourselves whether you are the
originator of that idea or not is
irrelevant
what it does is fuel passion
what it does is fuel conviction
so we don't have to have a vision but we
do have to find one
and so read books watch TED Talks read
articles be in life
watch videos you know go out seek find
listen listen to leaders corporate
political whoever and when something
resonates with you even if you don't
know why
that then you can adopt and you can take
it upon yourself to use your own talents
your own gifts to help Advance whatever
that cause is
right so I have a cause I have a Crystal
Clear Vision of the world I want to live
in I imagine a world in which the vast
majority of people wake up every single
morning inspired feel safe at work and
return home fulfilled at the end of the
day the gift that I have committed to
help advance that cause
is the ability to put some of these
ideas into words that other people can
relate to
you know when you do a jigsaw puzzle the
first thing you do is lean the Box
against the wall
right we all have a piece of the puzzle
to help build this Vision my piece of
the puzzle is I'm the guy that points at
the Box
but I'm not the guy who builds the
business
because there are other people who are
better at that the entrepreneurs and the
Business Leaders I want them to embrace
the same picture on the box
the people who work for companies who
say I want to work for a company that
does that that's their piece the one
who's a good A Gifted natural leader who
cares we all have at least one friend
who for whatever reason love us and Care
us even when we're horrible people
that that for some reason they still
believe in us and they see the good in
US
that's their piece of the puzzle
and so we have to commit our gifts the
reason they call them gifts is because
they're forgiving
that's what gifts are they're forgiving
away if you have a gift it's not
something you take it's something you
give
so I think we have to find a vision and
commit our gifts to help advance that
vision and the great leaders the ones
that can put that Vision into words so
clear
that we can then recite that Vision as
if it were our own there's a great story
told by Nelson Mandela he was actually
born the son of a tribal Chief and he
was asked by a journalist how did you
learn to become a great leader and he
said when I was a boy I remember two
things I remember going to tribal
meetings with my father and I remember
they always sat in a circle and my
father was always the last to speak and
if you think he's the most senior person
in the room he's this tribal Chief and
he was always the last to speak you know
we're constantly telling people you have
to be a better listener but at the end
of the day we have to speak eventually
and when we communicate but I think the
practice of being the last to speak when
you're in a meeting we do this all the
time the senior person comes and goes
okay this is what I think we should do
but I'm interested in what you have to
say well it's too late you buy us the
room it's over or you've made people
feel that their opinion doesn't matter
I'm tired of the term soft skills hard
skills are the skills we need to learn
to do our jobs and human skills of the
learn of the skills we need to be better
human beings and it's the combination of
hard skills and human skills that make
us very good and listening is one of
those so I think be coming into a
meeting stating a problem not giving an
opinion and literally be the last to
speak not only do you make people feel
like their opinions matter but you get
the benefit of new ideas you can still
make the same decision you wanted to
make at the beginning but you get all
that additional benefit so practice
being the last to speak that's a great
lesson the infinite game is not the
absence of finite games
um you can absolutely have arbitrary
goals and remember most of the financial
goals we set a few people sat in a room
and said what do we want our annual goal
to be and somebody says let's make it
this number and somebody goes no let's
make it this number and that becomes the
number right there's nothing wrong with
that absolutely nothing in fact it's
necessary you human beings are very
tangibly driven animals we like counting
things it's actually important can you
imagine running a marathon without mile
markers it would actually be unnerving
so metrics help us measure speed and
distance which is very very important
but we have to remember that when we hit
a metric or don't hit a metric the game
has not been won or lost
they're markers right and and that's the
important part so stop thinking we have
to stop thinking about business like a
race or a game and start thinking of it
like a lifestyle so for example I want
to be healthy right so there are many
things I have to do to be healthy I have
to eat right I have to exercise I have
to you know get enough sleep I have to
nourish my personal relationships
there's probably 15 or 20 other things
can't do all of those things well all
the time it's a striving same in
business we have unit wave product we
have marketing we have sales we have
leadership we can't do them all right
all the time it's a striving but we can
set arbitrary goals like I want to lose
x amount of weight by X date
right and every day I'm going to stand
on the scale some days I'll feel good
and some days I'll feel bad and when I
hit my goal I'm excited
um but the problem is I have to keep
exercising for the rest of my life like
it it hasn't ended simply because I hit
a goal and that's important to recognize
but what I find more interesting is what
happens if you miss the goal and the
answer is
nothing
nothing happens in fact very often we
just miscalculated the the time it'll
take to achieve it so if you're doing
all the right things and you you see the
trend data is is on path
and you just lose that weight in a month
later or two months later
okay you're healthier now even missing
the goal than you were before the the
bad news the where it gets dangerous is
when we're so obsessed with that goal
that I'll starve myself and stop
drinking water to hit the goal and I'm
actually unhealthy and companies do that
so the goals are good and celebrating
the wins are great and there are wins
that's fantastic but we have to remember
that if we miss the goal the question is
what's the trend data like are we a
healthy company are we taking care of
each other and I'll just go back a few
years ago
um
uh uh
Ginny remedy uh
IBM missed its numbers
and Ginny Romiti made of an internal
video which of course leaked made an
internal video
that was spread out set up to the entire
IBM that basically
all over the sales team publicly
and I remember talking to somebody at
IBM and I'm like What's with that video
and they're like oh so glad I'm not in
sales right and basically berated them
for missing the numbers
this was the first time IBM had missed
its numbers the first quarter in 69
quarters
and the CEO's response was to berate a
team the rate and higher division right
after 69 quarters they missed their
first one guess what happened after that
berating the team and what happened to
the culture and guess how many times
they missed it after that it continued
in other words it's fine it's fine to
miss it it's a game it's a long game so
I think that's where we get confused
which is we become obsessed with we
missed our numbers once we're we're
doing fantastic
you know so I think that's where it's
just about keeping things in perspective
that's why the infinite mindset helps
it's just about perspective so in the
mid 1980s a philosopher in Theologian by
the name of Dr James karst articulated
these two types of games finite games
and infinite games a finite game is
defined as known players
fixed rules and it agreed upon objective
football baseball
if there's a winner necessarily there
have to be losers and there's always a
beginning middle and an end right then
you have infinite games infinite games
are defined as known and unknown players
which means you don't necessarily know
who all the players are and new players
can join whenever they want
um uh the rules are changeable which
means every player can play however they
want and the objective is to perpetuate
the game to stay in the game as long as
possible
turns out we're players in infinite
games every day of our lives right
there's no such thing as
um winning global politics there's no
such thing as winning marriage you can't
be number one in your marriage you can
be number two but you can't be number
one right
um uh there's no such thing as winning
education
nobody wins learning you can come in
first for the finite amount of time
you're at school where we agree upon the
time frame and the uh uh and the metrics
grades but nobody wins education and
nobody wins business like when Circuit
City went bankrupt Best Buy didn't win
anything right
but if you listen to the language of so
many leaders half the room doesn't know
what Circuit City is I know it's sort of
I realize that it used to be a company
that competed with Best Buy same thing
Big Box store went in bought a VCR you
don't know what a VCR is right
um
what I love about this these definitions
is that when we listen to the language
of so many leaders it becomes abundantly
clear that they don't know the game
they're playing in the number of leaders
who talk about being number one being
the best or beating their competition
based on what based upon what agreed
upon metrics time frames or objectives
and this is a problem because when we
play with a finite mindset in an
infinite game when we play to win in a
game that has no finish line there's
some consistent and predictable outcomes
the big ones are the decline of trust
the decline of cooperation and the
decline of innovation so let's let's
translate that to a policing
organization right an infinite game is
not the absence of finite games it is
the context within which finite games
exist clearly you are engaged in finite
things every day of your career you have
a project that you need to complete
there's a beginning middle and end if
someone has committed a crime you want
to try and catch that person there is a
known objective there's a beginning
middle and end there's going to be a
winner there's going to be a loser right
if somebody you're chasing somebody down
for for a moving violation for example
this is these things are finite but
policing and the organization of the
Orange County sheriff is an infinite
organization we hope that this
organization outlasts everybody here and
thrives Beyond everybody here so the
decisions we make and the way we conduct
ourselves have to be considerate of the
fact that we want this organization to
thrive for the long term I mean you play
the infinite game for the good of the
game right right which is you're in the
hospitality industry for the good of the
hospitality industry and for the good of
all business and the best companies the
ones we love and admire right they share
you know it's it's the ones who are
protective you know of what they've
because they think it's a competitive
advantage and what they don't what they
fail to recognize is implementation is
the competitive Advantage not the idea
itself
execution is the competitive Advantage
but the ability to share the things you
believe in and the things you uh uh have
figured out yeah for the good of
business because we don't just believe
your employees should be treated well we
believe all employees should be treated
well you know and if we if you figured
things out so I'll tell you a story so
Bob Chapman is the CEO of a company
called Barry waymiller it's a company
I've written and spoken about quite a
lot especially in my book uh leaders at
last okay
um and you had the opportunity to meet
Bob Bob is one of those unique
remarkable leaders and the way I met Bob
is he'd read start with why and he sent
me a letter and saying I'm building the
kind of company that you've written
about
and I said I want to meet you and so we
had lunch in Los Angeles this Famous
Lunch
um where we were scheduled for an hour
and we both cleared our schedules and
spent the next three hours together
because we loved each other and I didn't
believe him I said you know I talk about
an ideal it's not realistic it's a night
it's a striving
he says no no I had it I said well I
want to see it to believe it so he
picked me up in his plane from New York
and we flew we spent three days flying
around the country to all these
different factories and it's a
manufacturing company right this is Blue
Collar some Union some non-union
manufacturing right
and
what I saw absolutely astonished me it
blew me away I've never seen anything
like it
um and he didn't prepare anything he let
me roam the factory floor without any I
could talk to anybody I could ask
anybody any question I wanted
there was no window dressing and I was
absolutely blown away and I'll just tell
you one quick story that really
exemplifies uh and this one's I haven't
written or spoken about this one so this
one was I haven't talked about this one
so they have a machine that was getting
old you know this is a factory big
machine yeah
um that's getting older need to be
replaced traditionally how large
machines are replaced is somebody in
procurement
fills out a list of requirements and
then goes in the market to find a
machine that fits a budget right that's
usually how it's done that's not how
they did it they went to the factory
floor to the two guys who work on that
machine one who's pretty young in his
early 20s one who's got more experience
uh neither of them have college
educations I think one had a GED
um and they said to them you need to
replace your machine you have a budget
of 750 000 go
and these two guys travel around the
country looking at I never came back
exactly
they now live in Tahiti uh they they uh
uh they give them a budget not the money
uh
smart uh they flew around the country
they they looked at new and used
machines and the people selling the
machine said they've never seen anything
like it they've never had anybody show
up in overalls climbing in the machine
usually it's a guy in a suit showing up
with a clipboard right you know they
ended up spending 650 000 so they were
really excited that they saved the
company money and that's their machine
right that's that I can guarantee that
machine will never break down right and
the trust and it makes perfect sense but
this is what one of the things that Bob
says you know Bob says is
we trust people who have college
educations who work in a back office and
we don't trust people who don't have
college educations what about their
education makes them trust where are
they untrustworthy he says I know some
pretty dishonest mbas you know uh
um and that's one of the things that Bob
did but the point was is we I went on
this wonderful tour with Bob and then we
finally went back to their corporate
headquarters in St Louis and the team
that had sort of built this culture was
sitting around a table and they were all
looking at me like this going isn't this
amazing like we built what you what you
wrote about
and I sat there and I said
I think you're the most selfish
organization I've ever met in my entire
life and they always sort of stunned
that I would say that I said look I
think it's amazing what you've built I
think it's absolutely incredible but how
selfish of you that you only offer this
thing this kind of thing that you've
built for 6 000 people what about the
millions of people who hate their jobs
who don't want to go to work every day
what are you doing for them
and it was on it was from that
conversation that Bob
opened the doors they now offer training
they now offer tours like Bob now he
wrote a book about it you know he's now
in the speaking circuit yeah he's out
there he's now a public figure
and he's promoting this new way of
leading and this new way of thinking
leader means other people follow what
you do
and if your brand stands for something
that people want to copy
and you're leading the way then clearly
you are competing against yourself and
not them but let them compete against
you
um and I think that the Four Seasons is
one of those Brands and I can't think of
anyone in the hospitality who has ever
done that who's ever reached outside of
their own
uh industry
that others want to be more like them
because you made it this far in a video
I want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you are special believe
Nation you made it here all the way to
the end and I love you so it's a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments Below on this video
I will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome for 10
more amazing rules from garyvee check
the video right there next to me I think
you'll love it continue to believe and
I'll see you there I have plenty going
on but the fact that I do what I want to
do enables all of it to work this is
grounded in something that is the
absolute answer for this entire Arena
the one thing I can